[Musique]
époque les
angers caen aventure les appels
ah le far west les revolvers les cow boy
woody nos amis thirith elliott et les do
thomas sont accueillis par un énorme
rayon laser qui traversent le ciel ils
doivent réparer le temps mais que
va-t-il leur arrivée j'en sais rien je
vous rappelle qu'on me filme plus des
scénarios on avance c'est décidé je fais
grève
qu'est ce qui a changé à cette époque le
rayon laser qui vient de traverser le
ciel et d'exploser cette maison on
trouve ça normal
cherchant des informations dans cette
seule zone bonjour des cow boys comme
dont west world se répand et vous
qu'avez-vous on veux aucun mal du ta
flamme bleue qu'on allait partir ok avec
plaisir on va taire sarcelles flamme
bleue aucune aider dit messieurs non
nous tuez pas pour l'amour de dieu
regardez on a seulement donné vulgaire
pistolet mais tout va bien nous sommes
des voyageurs qu'est ce qui se passe ici
les ordures nous a taxés en la salle
vous voulez dire c'est vous qui les
massacres et maintenant ils nous tuent
par s'entendre j'ai l'impression qu'on a
trouvé notre bouleversement temporel
cette flamme bleue il a une arme maudite
une lumière bleue qui transforme pour en
poussière ça doit être un canon à eau
des matières que notre ennemi à donner
aux autochtones mais oui vous connaissez
ce terme aux études ou s'il vous plaît
aidez nous nous les côtoyons néo pressé
non moins vous êtes sûr que c'est pas
vous qui avez commencé quoi embêter les
indiens n'ont rien fait on est super
sympa avec pas vrai les gars mais
capteurs détectent un gros pipeau quoi
ils seraient en train de mentir si la
vérité on est les victimes dans cette
histoire
vous vous rendez compte 50 notre couleur
de peau qui nous aiment pas ils sont
intolérants 6 janvier un mois ne dresse
pas compatir aux non plus pourtant j'ai
pleuré en des troupeaux mon premier
avocat
c'est en découpant des oignons que
plaire je ne connais pas c'est pour
saisir mais non ils nous tuent par
centaines les idées que les polos soeur
ce football ou fois ça fait plaisir
qu'on s'a se martyriser tu cherches la
bagarre hameau de plus à mon faible à
miss somme a dû passer et jean faut être
avec la colonne vertébrale de l'autre m
[Musique]
j'aurais pas je suis à savoir les
assécher les guerres de territoire entre
les peuples natifs et les colons sont
censés perdurer encore et même si on
peut trouver ça injuste
il faut rétablir l'histoire bon allons à
la rencontre du peuple natif bien le
village se trouve à quelques centaines
de mètres quelques proches
le chef de la tribu je suis flamme bleue
chef et protecteur de cette région
étrangers venez vous en faire ravva paix
et prospérité qu'elle est ce si demain
vous aussi vous voulez opprimés mon
peuple a dû tout on veut juste
comprendre ce qui se passe ici
avez vous vécu des événements et disons
une habituelle dans votre région il ya
une crue et la lune était
particulièrement bas à sierre ah oui
aussi il ya un maître de métal qui est
apparue du ciel et qui m'a donné une
arme capable de détruire les montagnes
voilà ça c'est inhabituel les méchants
robots qu'on ait vu chez léonard de
vinci est venu ici grâce à cette arme
nous avons pu repousser les envahisseurs
d'ailleurs toi bonhomme de métal tu me
rappelles l'esprit de si je ne suis pas
tout à fait comme eh bien figurez vous
que nous venons du même endroit que cet
être des cieux alors pouvons nous voir
la marque elle dit admirer la force du
ciel
c'est bien un canon longue portée m oz
675 l'antimatière je préfère l'appeler
flamme bleue très impressionnant qu'est
ce qu'on fait ses larmes la plus
puissante qui existe à notre époque l'an
2000 désolé c'est la poussière du désert
samba du passé et en a plein le dos et
on peut pas leur trang larmes ça va
condamner cette population a affronté
les cowboys et on sait comment ça se
termine pas faire ça le craquement - du
passé oui mais notre priorité est
d'empêcher les modifications du temps si
le temps s'y lit trop de changements
notre réalité s'effondrera le lapin ne
viendra pas nous chercher
me seront coincés ici et on laissera le
méchant réussir son plan machiavélique
qu'on n'a même pas vraiment compris on
peut pas faire ça
le clan avec momo du passé merci les
gars pour vos avis tranché elliott ça se
voit que t'es pas humain toi ça te fait
rien de laisser un peuple se faire au
prix mais pas humain toi tu as bien fait
couler le titanic
alors il y à petit bras ville dans le
fleuve
pradines
vraiment franchement nature non petites
brindilles et mon fils c'est son nom
dans le fleuve en rallye précipice
un enfant se noie il faut le sauver on
est trop loin ses chances de survie sont
de 0,06
attention il a sauté vraiment quoi je l
adore prendre des risques il a couvert
le danger comme un enfant vers un câble
en gaz c'est un bon petit bandit
magnifique
il s'agit de croo les papillons
attention pour son annonce dans l'eau
des passants
waouh
ça vient entre bramois ça va faire mal
ils montrent la paroi rocheuse avec un
seul bras et l'enfant sur les épaules
des vivants j'ai supporté comme j'ai pu
je crois que par les couleurs sont en
sécurité
où est mon bras cette blessure est
étrange
aucune trace de sang ni de chair ça
c'est pas humain de tous
je sais que comme il semble que ce soit
une matière synthétique est [ __ ]
polymorphe et tu en mousse je ne
comprends pas tout tout est en flammes
la feuillée perdre petit un défraiement
train de champion fra jaillit plongeant
seul dans les rapides le courant était
faux
l'enfant il plus porter l'ours brun a
d'abord pris un bras pour son goûter
un ses preuves
là je me
sacré sacré
non je t'assure ont repeint que mes
larmes gardel qui vont causer des soucis
contre nature n'ont rien à faire ici
défendre ses terres je rends mon nom
d'abord ont donné mes frères qui est
social jeu
[Musique]
ça sonne et mieux flammes le vous n'êtes
pas humain peuple du ciel je comprends
que cette arme ne devrait pas être ici
c'est contre nature
merci d'avoir sous les petites
brindilles nous lutterons comme avant
avec nos soeurs et nos flèches pour
maintenir le cours des choses et cette
arme parasites
je m'en débarrasse vous êtes tellement
classe
bon bah comme vous voudrez oui mais
avoue juste comme ça si vous avez
l'occasion passer aux armes à seulement
un petit but je suis de retour
cool on a dû réussir notre mission si le
petit la paella oui tout est bien qui
finit bien ouais enfin parle pour nous
petit lapin tu peux nous ramener aux
laboratoires
j'aimerais discuter avec mon père à
propos de thomas mais qu est-ce qu la
tomate route de bitche et l'est où sont
bas ah bon je vois mettez vous autour de
moi pour le voyage et des bonbons et
diverses boissons en coule des mentos
est ce que je peut charger mon téléphone
c'est un iphone ouais 417 au 418 parce
que c'est pas le même en bout ainsi
cesse je vais pas voir l'autorisation
et voilà on est arrivé mettez-moi 5
étoiles et je ferai pareil papa vous
êtes de retour
vous avez arrêté la personne qui modifie
les jeunes aiment pas ton retard c'est
quoi ça regardez mon moi qui ai futur il
a plus de bras et on dirait que son
corps est fait de bouts ce mois un truc
du genre si mélo ça pour être précis je
suis en coin mais qu'est ce que tu nous
cache papa j'avais tout vous dire j'ai
failli vous en parler mais j'ai eu peur
que vous le preniez mal thomas du futur
ne vient il pas dit si non plus en fait
c'est un peu compliqué vous voyez
l'ordinateur d'abord j'ai recréer
virtuellement le monde que nous
connaissons et ses habitants voient une
simulation de notre monde je veux un
monde virtuel
oui et figurez vous qu'on peut sortir
quelqu'un de la simulation
il suffit de taper son nom sur chaque
paquet c'est moi qui les fait sortir en
tapant nous exact comme du coup c'est
pas un thomas du futur donc je suis
plutôt ma du passé donc maintenant on
m'appelle thomas tout court et donc lui
c'est tom en mousse ça va comme en
mousse nous y retrouvons way thomas
oustry cruel thomas tout court désolé
thomas en boxe tu sort tout droit de
cette imprimante 3d est si mulhouse je
vais vous montrer
prenons un exemple je tape une colombe
omer dieppe et rouge
au départ je change la carte où chaque
mort ses comptes changer tout ta carte
tout ferme alors qu'il me reste une
journée du bleu ouais bah tout ça pour
qu'on dépense plus te jure
le petit oiseau blanc dumont taser elle
allait planter sandaré son venin est
fatale
c'est quoi ce bordel on n'a jamais vu
une colombe avec des dons et un dard
venimeux
oui non mais ça je sais mais c'est qu'à
cause de la simulation
à la base c'était un monde très paisible
suite à un problème du four de
l'affluence de la mort et du désespoir
pas part on est parti dans le temps avec
un frankenstein qui vient d'un monde
chaotique que tu as créé et nommé tu te
rends compte du danger dans quel qui
nous a dit tu vois et les russes quand
je vois comment tu réagir
je me dis que j'avais bien fait de vous
le cacher mais non avec ta logique de
merde allez on oublie tout ça je
rebranche thomas virtuel à son monde
je dois retourner là dedans net tout va
bien il va nous manquer et au mans voilà
j'ai juste un mètre ce petit câble
tentons oreilles
ah non je ne m'attaque à adam je dois
construire des explosifs
j'avais oublié de couper ça m'énerve
quelqu'un essaie encore de modifier le
temps qui sait
pour la vue c'est un robot on l'a croisé
chez leonardo dicaprio robot thomas en
mousse l'a fait fuir tel rebond ça on va
le savoir et le mettre hors d'état de
nuire
battus la par an mais nous aux cours
donnés c'est parti pour la ville de rome
en -100 avant jésus-christ parfait
allons-y je compte sur vous allez en
route thomas du passé auquel a vendu
thomas du futur provient en réalité d'un
monde virtuel
je n'en reviens pas et maintenant nos
héros vont dans la rome antique pour
arrêter ce satellite reboux fauteurs de
troubles pardon ma grève
à bondoukou j'étais tellement à fond
dans l'histoire mais que j'ai oublié
maghreb
merci d'avoir écouté cet épisode et à la
semaine prochaine pour la suite de
l'épopée temporel